[Music]
[Applause]
so
so
something the matter clock oh no sir
[Music]
class dismissed crypto you know better
than to come here
you want to give away my secret identity
you're trying to tell me there's trouble
somewhere huh
[Music]
then it must be a job for superboy
holy cow look at that mountain it's a
massive molten rock
come on we've got to dig a deep catch
for that lava before it flows into the
valley
[Music]
super calamities the freight train is
starting to roll back down the grade
and there's a passenger train stranded
at the bottom it's out of power too
i'll get this one friends stopping
trains is my specialty
california here i come jack the brakes
aren't holding look
we're hitting right for the 507.
[Music]
should be reaching donner pass any
moment now
there it is and not a moment too soon
jack it's superman
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
maybe we better get out of here not
without them
oh flash give me a hand oh
gross now
everybody stay close
[Music]
you should have stayed in whatever happy
fantasy the black mercy granted you
[Music]
happy
do you know what i've lost
[Music]
would i've
look up in the sky it's superman
[Music]
the son of krypton lives
but how long story brainiac
one i don't have time to share
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
superman stay here son
you fight for the wizard i fight for
those who can't fight for themselves
[Music]
[Music]
where's that shield coming from it's
superman somehow he's extending his own
bioelectric field
superman where are you
i should easily be able to intercept it
before it detonates
[Music]
please
[Music]
superman can't talk now
wow
no
[Music]
long live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it ends today ends without a single loss
of life
you're a long way from metropolis well
there seems to be a lot more action in
your town these days
nothing i can't handle on my own with
robin's help
yes batman buildings vanishing in thin
air seems bigger than the joker
if he and lex luthor have joined forces
you and i should consider doing the same
i don't know how joker thinks and you
don't know the extent of luth or
scientific genius
he could have shrunk the treasury and
stuck it in a bottle for all you know
i appreciate your candor but if the
treasury is anywhere in gotham
i'll find it i know my city inside and
out
every corner of every dark alley
maybe they're hiding it in the french
quarter robin we don't have a french
quarter
uh don't you
me superman what was that i couldn't
hear you over the sound of my talking to
other friends
what what's this weird thing gee i don't
know i wouldn't want to bother you
oh come on i love it when you save me
from stuff and then we hang out
really i mean for real and we can go to
the game tomorrow
yes oh what a great game
right best friend yeah it is pretty
great
best by friend
just like every other one in this game
why didn't you tell me luthor was
involved i was handling it
yeah looks like you had it all under
control
look i'll hang around and give you a
hand remember
i can do anything
you know who's in there what kryptonite
that's what they wanted the whole time
it must be what powers that
deconstructing device
i picked up kryptonite on the batmobile
scanner so now they can neutralize your
gadgets and my powers
question is why what are they up to i
don't know
but tomorrow is election day so we're
running out of time
we'll just have to go ask lex luthor
you're just going to walk right into
lexcorp headquarters
yep you worried superman does not worry
we could take this to get there
introducing the new
flying fat boat
you need a hand no i'm good
this is no joke i won't be able to
[Applause]
breathe
[Music]
please be enemies mongol we can settle
our business
later
wonder woman i have joker rendezvous
with the docking bay
clearing the path be there soon
[Music]
mongol not here to fight
you
all right have it your way go superman
yuck
perimeter secured superman do you copy
[Music]
[Music]
you